1,6 millionen euro für eine brücke das
klingt ehrlich gesagt erst mal nach
einem relativ fairen deal aber die
brücke ist für fledermäuse gemacht und
erbaut von der deutschen bahn
ganz ehrlich das muss man nicht direkt
verstehen sondern sollte sich erst mal
fragen
ist das nicht eine absolute
geldverschwendung oder eben doch
lobenswerter tierschutz und genau diese
frage möchte ich jetzt meinen kollegen
sebastian prengel stellen erst für uns
in mülheim sebastian sag uns was soll
das ganze überhaupt naja die tournee
fall muss man sagen dass peter moss
brücken nichts ungewöhnlich geschwind
die gibt es mittlerweile an
verschiedenen stellen in ganz europa und
die werden deshalb gebaut weil experten
vermuten dass autobahn oder eben
bahngleise ein unüberwindbares hindernis
für die tiere darstellen könnten
und normalerweise wird das dann so
gemacht dass man steine über die straße
oder über die gleise spannt und daran
orientieren sich die tiere dann mittels
ultraschall dabei bleiben dann auch die
kosten überschaubar das liegt dann in
einem rahmen zwischen 50 und 100 tausend
euro in diesem fall ist allerdings etwas
ganz anderes da hat die deutsche bahn
den fledermäusen eine regelrechte
autobahn weil diebe am kreisel gebaut
die s8 die brücke ist acht meter hoch
elf meter breit 31 meter lang und hat
wie gesagt 1,6 millionen euro gekostet
und warum steht sie jetzt genau da wo
sie eben steht und vor allem wie
hilfreich ist diese autobahn für die
fledermäuse am ende dann tatsächlich
naja also dieser landstrich ist ein
wichtiges einzugsgebiet für fledermäuse
die spanische schlafen am rande des
schwarzwalds und jagen in der rheinebene
und auf diesem wege kreuzen sie auch die
gleise wie haben sie bislang im auge
hatte ich einen kleinen aber im zuge des
ausbaus ist dieser bahnstrecke ist auch
der tunnel vergrößert worden und jetzt
befürchten die experten dass die mäuse
sich dann nicht mehr richtig orientieren
können und deshalb hat man genau an
dieser stelle diese brücke gebaut
die wird jetzt übrigens auch noch
richtig schön begrünt damit die damit
sich möglichst viele insekten wieder
lassen und die fledermäuse auf ihrem weg
so etwas wie eine raststätte haben mit
insekten snacks und jetzt ist der punkt
dass man überhaupt gar nicht weiß ob
diese räder mautbrücken überhaupt einen
nutzen haben das ist wissenschaftlich
überhaupt nicht erwiesen dass ist im
gegenteil es ist sogar sehr umstritten
vielen dank sebastian bringe für diese
erklärungen rund um die brücke extra für
fledermäuse dankeschön
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren